[موسيقى]
لم يكد يجف حبر اجتماع العقبه حتى اقتحم
عشرات المستوطنين تحت حمايه قوات الاحتلال
بلده حواره بضفه الغربيه مضربين النيران
في ممتلكات اهلها لم تكن تلك الاعتداءات
اول انتهاك لنتائج لقاء العقبه وقد سبقها
تنصل حكومه نتنياهو من الالتزام بتجميد
بناء الوحدات والبؤر الاستيطانيه بالنسبه
الى الاطراف الراعيه فان الاجتماع مجرد
بدايه تستوجب الكثير من العمل خلال
الاسابيع والاشهر المقبله من خلال التنسيق
الامني بين الجانبين الاسرائيلي
والفلسطيني لتحقيق اهدافه المعلنه بخفض
التصعيد ومنع المزيد من العنف لكنه في نظر
الكثير من الفلسطينيين لا يختلف عن غيره
من الاتفاقات السابقه وان هدفه الحقيقي هو
تصفيه المقاومه الفلسطينيه المتصاعده في
الضفه الغربيه خشيه تطورها الى انتفاضه
ثالثه فما هي الطبيعه وواقعيه التفاهمات
بين الجانبين الفلسطيني والاسرائيلي في
اجتماع العقبه وهل ان هذا النوع من
التفاهمات كفيل بخفض التوتر اما العكس هو
الصحيح مع استمرار الاحتلال وغياب اي افق
سياسي اهلا بكم في هذه الحلقه الجديده من
سيناريوهات
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ما حدث في الاردن سيبقى في
الاردن هذا ما قاله وزير الامن القومي
الاسرائيلي اليميني المتطرف
بينما تحدى وزير الماليه مخرجات قمه
العقبه حين قال انه لن يتم تجميد البناء
الاستيطاني ولو ليوم واحد تصريحات القت
بظلال كثيفه من الشك على الالتزامات
المعلنه في اجتماع العقبه وعكست حقيقه
المخاوف من ايام صعبه مقبله
لمعرفه ما تبقى من اجتماع العقبه في ظل
هذه المواقف اليمنيه المتطرفه والاوضاع
المتوتره يسعدنا ان نستضيف هنا في
الاستوديو الدكتور ابراهيم فريحات استاذ
النزاعات الدوليه في معهد الدوحه للدراسات
العليا من رام الله هاني المصري مدير مركز
مسارات لابحاث السياسات ومن واشنطن
المتحدث السابق باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه فاهلا بهم جميعا
الوضع المتوتر في الاراضي المحتله تصاعد
بشكل لافت خلال الاشهر الاخيره بعد عوده
بن يمينه ياهو الى السلطه ضمن ائتلاف غير
مسبوق مع احزاب يمينيه متطرفه جدا وفي ظل
رفضا امريكي معلن لسياسه حكومه نتنياهو ضد
الفلسطينيين ومعارضه شعبيه كبيره ومتزايده
لسياسات حكومته جاء اجتماع العقبه الذي
روج له كبادره فراش لكنه اتضح سريعا جدا
انه حمل كاذب
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
هنا في الضفه الغربيه وضع متفجر لا تفتح
الاحداث تؤكد انه ماض نحو مزيد من التصعيد
وهنا في اسرائيل يشد المحتجون ازرهم في
معارضه السياسات الحكومه الاسرائيليه
بخصوص تعديلات نظام القضاء
مشهدان يحاصران نتنياهو وحكومته فجاء
الطريق الى اجتماع العقبه بمبادره امريكيه
في محاوله الامتصاص الغليان الفلسطيني في
الضفه الغربيه وانقاذ نتنياهو من مازقه
بعدما فقد السيطره على الواقع السياسي وفق
ما ذكرت صحيفتها
من لقاء العقبه هو ايجاد صيغه لوقف
التصعيد في الضفه فانما اعقب الاجتماع من
مواقف ينذر بصعوبه تحقيق ذلك
فقد تضمنت نتائج اللقاء التزاما اسرائيليا
بوقف مناقشه اقامه اي وحدات استيطانيه
جديده لمده اربعه اشهر ووقف اقرار اي بؤر
استيطانيه جديده لمده سته اشهر
لكننا تنياه نفسه صرح لاحقا ان البناء
الاستيطاني وتشريع البؤر الاستيطانيه في
الضفه الغربيه سيتواصلان دون اي تغيير فمن
الذي قدم الالتزام في اجتماع العقبه ومن
الذي سينفذه
في جميع محافظات الوطن في الجانب
الفلسطيني ينظر من جانب فصائل المقاومه
الى يوميات جنين ونابلس واريحا على انها
براهين الاستحاله الثقه في امكانيه خفض
التصعيد من الجانب الاسرائيلي وزير
الماليه الاسرائيلي
دعا في تصريحات مثيره الى محو قريه حوار
الفلسطينيه في نابلس بينما تتوالى
الاعتقالات والاقتحامات التي تنفذها قوات
الاحتلال في عموم الضفه الغربيه والقدس
خربوا
بالنسبه لفصائل المقاومه لا حاجه لترقب ما
يحدث بعد لقاء العقبه للحكم على مخرجاته
فالاذرع العسكريه التابعه لفصائل المقاومه
الفلسطينيه في مخيم جنين قالت ان السلطه
الفلسطينيه بمشاركتها في الاجتماع وقعت في
الفخ الامريكي مره اخرى باستجابتها لضغوط
واشنطن التي لا يهمها سوى مصالح الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي وحمايه امنه بينما طالبت
الفصائل في قطاع غزه برفض التعاطي مع
الخطط الاسرائيليه والامريكيه التي تستهدف
حسبها الشعب الفلسطيني ومقاومته لكن ما
تسرب بشان الخطه الامنيه الامريكيه
المسماه خطه فينزل لتعزيز التنسيق الامني
وتطويق المقاومه يعزز احتمالات الصدام وقد
يمضي بالتصعيد الى مستويات اعلى
ورغم نفي السلطه الفلسطينيه على لسان حسين
الشيخ رئيسي وفد السلطه في اجتماع العقبه
لوجود خطه امنيه امريكيه الا ان حديثا
كثيرا تداولته وسائل الاعلام العبريه عن
خطه امنيه امنيه امريكيه للجنرال مايك
بنزل منسق الشؤون الامنيه في السفاره
الامريكيه في اسرائيل
اشرت القناه الرابعه عشره العبريه تفاصيل
الخطه التي وضعها الجنرال الامريكي
منسق الشؤون الامنيه في السفاره الامريكيه
في تل ابيب والتي تهدف الى اعاده سيطره
الاجهزه الامنيه الفلسطينيه على محافظتي
جنين ونابلس وفرض التهدئه وفقا للقناه
القناه قالت في تقريرها ان السلطه
الفلسطينيه قابلت بالخطه بشكل مبدئي وهذا
جزء من التفاهمات التي توصلت اليها اداره
بين السلطه والحكومه الاسرائيليه مؤخرا
وترص الخطه التي نشرتها القناه على تدريب
نحو خمسه الاف عنصر من الاجهزه الامنيه
كقوات خاصه فلسطينيه على الاراضي الاردنيه
باشراف امريكي وقد وافق كل من الاردن ومصر
على برنامج التدريب حسب القناه تبدا هذه
القوه بالعمل داخل المدن والمخيمات في
نابلس وجنين تحت قياده غرفه عمليات مشتركه
بهدف استعاده سيطره السلطه على المدينتين
ووفقا للخطه المسربه فان دخول القوات
الفلسطينيه الى المقر الجديده في جنين
ونابلس سيتم بالتزامن مع تقليص كبير لنشاط
الجيش الاسرائيلي في اطار التنسيق الامني
تحت اشراف امريكي وهذا البند من الخطه
الامريكيه هو احد الشروط الفلسطينيه
لقبولها بكاملها وتنص الخطه على تغير
توجهات السلطه الفلسطينيه في التعاطي مع
المقاتلين الفلسطينيين وتغيير النهج الذي
تعاملت به السلطه في المرحله الماضيه معهم
اذ حاولت فتح قنوات اتصال واقناعهم
بالتخلي عن المقاومه والانضمام الى الامن
مقابل
حوافز ماليه وهو ما يجب وقفه في المرحله
الجديده
دكتور ابراهيم فريحات اهلا وسهلا بك
في البدايه نريد ان نفهم حصل التفاهمات
معينه في
اجتماع العقبه ام لم يحصل اي شيء من هذا
الكلام
ما حدث في العقبه هو حصل هناك تفاهمات ولم
يحصل اتفاقيات وهناك فرق شاسع ما بين
التفاهمات والاتفاقيات التفاهمات هي حصلت
حول ضروره خفض التوتر الامني على
الجانبين وايضا تفاهمات حول استمرار
اللقاءات في المستقبل واستمرار التنسيق
وايضا حصل هناك تفاهم حول موضوع
المستوطنات التي اثارت كل هذا اللغط وشتت
الموقف يعني خرجت تصريحات متناقضه
التفاهمات فيما يخص المستوطنات هي تقول
بضروره وقف تراخيص جديده
للمستوطنات وليس وقف الاستيطان وهناك فرق
شاسع ما بين وقف
تراخيص جديده وتشريع مستوطنات وبؤره
استيطانيه وما بين وقف النشاط الاستيطاني
النشاط الاستيطاني لم يحدث حوله تفاهمات
وهذا متاكد بالمناسبه ما تصريحات بنيامين
نتنياهو التي لا تتعارض بالمناسبه مع ما
حدث في اجتماع العقبه لم يحدث اتفاق على
وقف النشاط الاستيطاني في العقبه وباعتقاد
هذا كان خطا كبير لان مساله اصدار تصاريح
جديده وتراخيص جديده وتشريع الاستطانيه هو
بطبيعه الحال ياخذ اربع شهور او ست شهور
او احيانا عام فلا يوجد هناك اي شيء جديد
حول هذه التفاهمات بينما لب وجوهر المشكله
المتمثل بالنشاط الاستيطاني لم يحصل عليه
تفاهم وباعتقاد هذا كان خطا كبير المساله
المرتبطه فيما بين التفاهمات والاتفاقيات
ان الاتفاقيات هي تتبع بخطوات عمليه بعكس
التفاهمات الذي يكون هناك تضع تصور
للمرحله القادمه ولما يمكن عمله التطبيقات
لاتفاقيات لم تحصل تخفيض التوتر لم يحصل
على الجانبين لا الجانب ولا على الجانب
الفلسطيني بالمناسبه ولم نرى اي انتشار
امني فلسطيني في المنطقه او حتى تدريب
رجال امن فلسطينيين في الاردن او غيره كما
نصت التفاهمات وانما بقيت في اطار
التفاهمات حول رؤيه المرحله القادمه وهي
التي ايضا يعني تقول بها وتدعم مثل هذا
التحليل هي خطه
في ضروره او بوضع تصور للمرحله والتصور هو
يتناسب مع التفاهمات
والمشكله الكبرى نقطه اخيره اذا سمحت
لمحمد
المشكله الكبيره في مثل خطه بهذا الجانب
هو هي ان الخطه الامنيه هي تفتقد الى افق
سياسي لا يوجد هي غير مرتبطه بافك سياسي
وانما مساله
جانب امني بحت وهذا يخدر المشكله ويسكن
المشكله ويعطي غطاء للنشاط الاستيطاني
الذي لم يحدث لا تفاهمات ولا اتفاقات
بخصوصه وهذا الخطوره فيما حدث في اتفاق
العقبه هذا الشرح للدكتور فريحات السيد
هاني المصري هل يمكن ان يفسر لنا هذا
الغلق اللغط الذي جرى بعد العقبه خاصه وان
اسرائيل لم تنتظر ولا يوم واحد لا من حيث
التصريحات ولا من حيث الممارسات
شكرا على الاستضافه انا يعني اود ان اضيف
ان المدخل لهذا الاجتماع كان مدخلا خاطئا
من حيث الاساس لان المقاربه التي تقول ان
التصعيد سببه وجود يعني كتائب من المقاومه
الفلسطينيه في جنين ونابلس وعدم سيطره
يعني السلطه الفلسطينيه على هذه الكتائب
وعلى هذه المنطقه هذا مدخل خاطئ لان سبب
التصعيد الاساسي ان لم يكن الوحيد هو
الاحتلال وما يقوم به الاحتلال من عمليات
قتل هدم منازل
اعتقالات
اعتداءات على الاقصى يعني قرار قوانين
عنصريه ضد الاسرى و ضد الفلسطينيين بشكل
عام كل هذه المسائل هي الجزر الاساسي
للتصعيد وخاصه في ظل وجود حكومه اسرائيليه
انتقلت من خطاب ادا الصراع او تقليص
الصراع الى خطاب السياده الاسرائيليه على
ارض اسرائيل الكامله وهذا الامر ضمن
برنامج متكامل يمكن ان نسميه برنامج الضم
والتهجير والتهويد ومن خلال العدوان
العسكري وبالتالي ان توافق السلطه
الفلسطينيه على الدخول الى هذا اللقاء
بدون اي التزامات اسرائيليه مسبقه وبعد ان
قامت اسرائيل بمجزره لان كان هناك بدايه
للتفاهمات هي الاتفاق الذي تم حول تاجيل
يعني عرض مشروع القرار على مجلس الامن
مقابل ان يكون هناك تهدئه من جانب اسرائيل
وان يفتح هذا الطريق للاجتماع يعني في
العقبه ماذا حدث اسرائيل لم تلتزم وانما
نفذت مجزره في نابلس وهي مجزره غير مسبوقه
هذا من جهه من جهه اخرى يعني الذي يقرا
بيان العقبه لا يوجد فيه تجميل للاستيطان
ابدا يعني للاسف وسائل الاعلام منها يتحدث
ان هذا البيان يتحدث عن تجميد للاستيطان
هو تحدث عن وقف مناقشه اقرار وحدات
استيطانيه جديده واقرار بؤر استيطانيه
جديده لماذا لان الحكومه الاسرائيليه اقرت
قبل هذا الاجتماع اقامه عشر الاف وحده
استيطانيه وهذا العدد اكثر من ضعف يعني
العدد الذي اقر في العام الماضي
ويوازي اكثر من الذي اقر في العامين
السابقين اذا لا يوجد يعني وقف وانما وقف
اقرار وحدات استيطانيه جديده وكذلك الامر
بالنسبه للبؤره الاستيطانيه حتى بالنسبه
لتقليص يعني نشاط وعدوان قوات الاحتلال
رئيس الوفد الاسرائيلي في العقبه قال اننا
لم نلتزم باي قيود على نشاطات الجيش
الاسرائيلي اذا كل ما تم الحديث عنه تهدئه
من قبل اسرائيل هو نوع من الخداع بصراحه
وزر الرماد في العيون هم الكل مازوم ولكن
الطرف الضعيف من هذه الاطراف جميعا هو
الجانب الفلسطيني وبالتالي الضغط يتعرض له
الجانب الفلسطيني وبالتالي هو الذي يخضع
لا يوجد في يده اوراق قوه لا يوجد وحده
فلسطينيه لا المقاومه التي تجري بمعزل عن
السلطه وعن القياده لا يوجد سلطه اصلا
للقياده عليها المقاومه في قطاع غزه لا
تدين بالولاء ولا مرجعيتها القياده
الفلسطينيه والشعب في حاله هو وكبيره بينه
وبين قيادته نتيجه اخطاء كثيره ارتكبتها
القياده من ضمنها الاستمرار في عمليه
سياسيه بعد موت هذه العمليه السياسيه
والرهان على احيائها رغم ان امكانيه
احيائها معدومه اذا الموضوع هو الضغط على
الجانب الفلسطيني واذا وافق الجانب
الفلسطيني على ما يراد له هذا يعني فتنه
فلسطينيه لان اذا قررت السلطه الفلسطينيه
ان تقوم بدور قوات الاحتلال في نابلس وفي
جنين وفي بقيه المناطق هذا سيؤدي الى
اقتتال فلسطيني لان اشكاله
مع ذلك المصري اسمح لي مع ذلك ورغم كل ما
اشرت اليه كان هناك
ترحيب امريكي واضح سيد بيجيكراولي على على
لسان جاك سليمان مستشار الامن القومي رحب
بما جرى في اجتماع العقبه هل كانت ترحيبا
سابقا لاوانه وليس في محله
لا اعتقد ان الامر كان مبكرا على المرء ان
يدرك ان توافقات العقبه كانت محدوده
والافق والهدف لم يكن هو حل المشكل من
اصله كانت فقط محاوله للعمل بشكل مشترك
خلال سته اشهر القادمه من اجل تخفيض
التوتر والعوده الى الوضع الذي كان سائدا
في السابق هذا قد
يؤدي نتائجه كما انه قد لا يؤدي تلك
النتائج الهدف الان هو محاوله اعاده بناء
جسور الحوار ما بين الفلسطينيين هذه
الجسور الذي انهارت منذ سنوات اذا
امكانيات تتفقد العقبه محدوده ولكن لماذا
لا تكون جسور الحوار هذه كما سميتها سوى
جسور امنيه وتفاهمات
على ضبط الوضع هنا وهناك في حين ان يفترض
ان تكون المقاربه سياسيه والامني يتبع
السياسي وليس العكس
نعم في الواقع
الامن هو احد الابعاد المرتبطه بالعلاقه
الفلسطينيه الاسرائيليه وهذا التعاون كان
ناجحا ليس هناك علاقه سياسيه بين نتنياهو
وبين محمود عباس هناك كان علامه ثقه ما
بين الطرفين
وكانوا في نفس القاع منذ او لفتره متعدده
ولمناسبات ومساعده وليس هناك تواصل بينهما
اذن العمل الان ينكبو على الامور التي نجح
فيها الطرفان في السابق اي التعاون الامني
وهذا ما رايناه في السابق ومن تم يمكن
الانطلاق باتجاه افق سياسي لكن هذا الافق
لن يكون ممكنا مع الحكومه الاسرائيلي
الراهنه اذا في هذه الحاله هل هل سحب
مشروع المتعلق بالاستيطان من مجلس الامن
والاكتفاء ببيان رئاسي الكل صوت عليه بما
في ذلك الولايات المتحده وهذا يحصل منذ
منذ سنوات عديده هل هل هذا يبشر بخطوات
امريكيه في المستقبل مع الملف الفلسطيني
تحديدا
الواقع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه مستمره
في تقديم دعمها للشعب الفلسطيني لكن
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ايضا لديها
علاقات ايضا
بالسلطه الفلسطينيه الرئيس عباس انتقدت
دور الامريكي في ظل اداره
وبعيد ايضا وقال بان امريكا ليست وسيطا
موثوق به اذا الان نحن بصدد محاوله بناء
كل شيء من ليس هناك الان علاقه وثيقه ما
بين حتى حكومه نتنياهو ايضا اذا هناك حاجه
لبناء كل شيء منذ البدايه وننظر ما الذي
يمكن ان نحققها وما الذي يمكن البناء عليه
وكيف يمكن
حوار سياسي انا طبعا
لكن من الضروري ان نحاول ان نبدا من حيث
كانت الامور قبل التوتر وتحديدا الدكتور
فريحات ما الذي يمكن البناء عليه الان
يعني بعد اجتماع العقبه هل هل هل من خطوات
مقبله لان قيل بان كان يفترض ان يكون هناك
اجتماع في شرم الشيخ ربما خلال شهر مارس
اذار الحالي في هذه الحاله ربما مستبعد
تماما يعني هذا يتوقف على القياده
الفلسطينيه الحاليه واستعدادها الى
التعاطي مع مثل هكذا خطوات هي غير مجديه
وبيجي كراولي بنفسه يقر بهذا يعني كما
تحدث الان بانه لا مجال للاتفاق مع هذه
الحكومه اليمينيه الفاشيه في تل ابيب
فالخطوره بالموقف الفلسطيني ان يشارك بمثل
هذه اللقاءات هو انه يعطي شرعيا لمثل هذه
الحكومه ويخفف الضغط الدولي عليها
والازمات التي تعايشها مع اطراف دوليه
كثيره بالامس كان وزير خارجيه اسرائيل في
المانيا وهي الصدر الاوسع لاسرائيل
والحامل اكبر واكثر من الولايات المتحده
واقرت وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه ان هناك
مشاكل لم تسبق لم يسبق لها مثيل مع هذه مع
اسرائيل في ظل وجود مثل هذه الحكومه
اليمينيه والتي بدات تتناقض ليست فيما يخص
الفلسطيني ولكن فيما يخص المبادئ
الديمقراطيه والايدلوجيه للغرب وللمانيا
تحديدا مثل قضيه وقف الاعداء مثل قضيه
تشريع الاعدام بالنسبه الى الفلسطينيين
وكانت حاده جدا وزيره الخارجيه الامريكيه
في نقض هذه المساله ان هذا يتناقض مع كتب
المدارس التي ندرسها في المانيا بهذا
الاتجاه وايضا من هناك فيما يخص الجانب
الديمقراطي وقضيه المعركه القضائيه التي
تخوضها الحكومه الاسرائيليه في اسرائيل
هذه مشاكل هي ليست بسبب الفلسطينيين ولكن
سبب التناقض الايدلوجي مع الغرب مع
المانيا ومع الولايات المتحده في مثل هذه
الاثناء ان تجتمع القياده الفلسطينيه بمثل
هذه الحكومه هي اعطاء انطباع للراي العام
العالمي انه يمكن العمل مع مثل هذه
الحكومه التي صرح الوزير الماليه فيها انه
يجب محو قريه حوار عن الوجود هو يدعو الى
الجينوسايد يدعو الى الاباده الجماعيه
يعني لا ادري هذا بالنسبه الى الاداره
الامريكيه كيف يمكن لها وبيجي كراوليسمع
بهذا الكلام انه سمع مثل هذه التصريحات
وهناك دعوه الى اباده جماعيه في حواره من
قبل وزير الماليه ويمكن للحكومه الامريكيه
ان تضع خطط امنيه للتعامل مع هذه الحكومه
والتعامل مع التشاهد المشكله هي عبرت عن
استهجان غير غير مسبوق عندما يقول المتحدث
باسم الخارجي الامريكيه بان هذه تصريحات
مثيره قزاز هل ترى في هذا الموقف ما يمكن
ان يبنى عليه لا لا لا
ارى سيرفس يعني خدمات كلاميه لا اكثر ولا
اقل الحكومه الامريكيه اداره الرئيس بايدن
تعرف تماما جوهر هذه جوهر هذه الحكومه
والعناصر الفاشيه الموجوده بهذه الحكومه
وتعرفها تماما وليست بحاجه حتى الى
تصريحات سمورتش مشان من اجل ان تعرف حقيقه
مثل هذه الحكومه والحكومه الامريكيه
بتعاطيها مع هذا الموضوع هي متواطئه مع
هذه الحكومه الفاشيه العنصريه التي تصدر
مثل هذه التصريحات ولا تتخذ موقف تخيل لو
ان مثل هذا التصريح صدر عن وزير فلسطيني
كيف سيكون هناك الرد الامريكي وكيف يكون
الرد الغربي هذا هو الموقف المشكله
بالنسبه الى القياده الفلسطينيه مجرد
الاجتماع واللقاءات مع هذه الحكومه التي
لا تتعهد بوقف ليس بنا ليس الطراخيص
الجديده ولكن وقف النشاط الاستيطاني هذا
هو الخط الفاصل بالنسبه
ترى في الفلسطيني هذا هو الخط الاحمر الذي
لا يمكن ولا يجب التحدث بخصوصه اما ان يقف
النشاط الاستيطاني وليس الطرف الجديده او
لا يوجد هناك مجال للحديث لان اي حديث واي
تفاهمات هي على حساب تشريع النشاط
الاستيطاني في فلسطين وهذا ما عملت عليه
الاسرائيليين منذ 93 حتى هذه الان وسنبقى
نتحدث بتفاهمات والى اخره فاذا اما ان
يكون وقف نشاط استيطاني او لا يكون هناك
حديث انت ذكرتني هنا الدكتور فريحات فيما
يتعلق بالنشاط الاستيطاني في
بدايه التسعينات عندما قررت منظمه التحرير
الفلسطينيه الدخول لمؤتمر مدريد
عقد اجتماع للمجلس الوطني الفلسطيني في
الجزائر واقر المشاركه كان احمد عبد
الرحمن
الراحل وكان متحدث باسم منظمه التحرير كان
يتحدث انذاك
ضروره وقف الاستيطان لدخول مفاوضات مدريد
نعم يعني يعني المساله عندها 30 سنه ونحن
نكرر نفس نفس الدرس ضروري توقف ضروره
ضروره وقف الاستيطان لدخول مفاوضات مدريد
تخيل منذ 30 عاما ما الذي حصل من السيطان
اسال السيد هاني المصري الغضب الشديد الذي
لقاه اجتماع العقبه من قبل الفلسطينيين
سواء في غزه او في الضفه ومن قبل الفصائل
ومن قبل شخصيات عديده من بينهم
[موسيقى]
حنان عشراوي
يعني شخصيات عديده
عبرت عن موقف غاضب هل هل هذا سيمنع
القياده في المستقبل من الانخراط في
توجهات من هذا القبيل
نعم معك حق المعارضه لهذا الاجتماع وما
نتج عنه هي معارضه تكاد تكون جماعيه من
الفصائل من المؤسسات من الشخصيات حتى داخل
حركه فتح هناك معارضه لهذا اللقاء وهذا
لسبب بسيط ان اسرائيل خلال ثلاثه عقود
الماضيه اقامت واقع كامل يمهد الطريق بشكل
واسع لتصفيه القضيه الفلسطينيه وقضايا
الوضع النهائي بشكل كامل وتاتي هذه
الحكومه وهي مقتنعه بان الثمار ناضجه
لتصفيه القضيه الفلسطينيه وحتى نتاكد من
ذلك علينا ان نعرف ان سموتريتش طرح خطه
اسمها خطه الحسم في عام 2017 وعلى فكره
وافق عليها نتنياهو هذه الخطه مستوحاه من
يهو شعب النون قبل الفين سنه قبل ان يقتحم
اريحا عندما وضع
خيارات امام اهل اريحا الولاء التام بدون
اي حقوق او الهجره او القتل هذا وطبعا
يضاف لها
تصفيه القضيه الفلسطينيه لان يعني هؤلاء
لا يريدوا اي تعبير عن هويه وطنيه
فلسطينيه والهويه الوطنيه الفلسطينيه هي
الهدف الرئيسي لكي يتم يعني تمهيد الطريق
لضم الضفه الغربيه وخاصه مناطق جيم بشكل
كامل اذا الدخول في لقاءات مع هذه الحكومه
يعطيها شرعيه بدلا من رفع شعار بضروره
مقاطعه هذه الحكومه بمروره فرد العقوبات
عليها مطالبه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
بان تضع يعني حزب سموت على قائمه المنظمات
الارهابيه حتى قبل تصريحاته الفاشيه والذي
تحدث فيها عن محو يعني حواره واكثر من ذلك
قال ان التجربه التي
كانت تجربه ناجحه
ويساعده على ذلك بصراحه وبكل مراره ان
ردود الفعل الفلسطينيه والعربيه والدوليه
على هذه التصريحات لم تكن في مستوى
الجريمه ولم تكن في مستوى الخطر لاحظنا
كيف الاداره الامريكيه عطلت صدور بيان من
مجلس الامن حول هذا الامر رغم انها تنتقد
ما جرى في حواره ولكن توفر الغطاء دائما
السياسي والقانوني للحكومه الاسرائيليه
حتى اذا اختلفت مع الحكومه الاسرائيليه في
بعض الجوانب لذلك يجب ان يكون هناك تغيير
في المسار الفلسطيني القياده الفلسطينيه
حتى الان لا يوجد ما يوحي بانها مستعده
لذلك ولذلك على القوى الاخرى على الشعب
الفلسطيني ان يمارس الضغط السياسي والشعبي
على هذه القياده ولا يرتكن الى اي وعود او
اي اتفاقات يعني من الحكومه الاسرائيليه
لان اسرائيل انتهكت
يعني مواثيق وقرارات دوليه ثلاثه اضعاف ما
انتهكت كل دول العالم وبالتالي نحن لسنا
بحاجه الى تجربه جديده يجب ان نعرف ان
المفاوضات ليس شطاره بالكلام المفاوضات هي
عندما تكون قادر على توظيف المتغيرات
وعناصر القوه وتحقيق انجازات سياسيه ونحن
في وضع ضعف وتشتت وانقسام بحاجه الى ترتيب
البيت الفلسطيني بحاجه الى وضع رؤيه
وبرنامج فلسطيني وشراكه حقيقيه حتى نجمع
اوراق القوه والضغط ونكون قادرين على فرض
يعني
استجابه للحقوق الفلسطينيه وفعلا
ابسط شرط يضعه الجانب الفلسطيني هو وقف
الاستيطان بكل اشكاله بدونه لا يجب حتى
اللقاء لا يوجد حتى فتح القناه لان السلطه
الفلسطينيه ارتكبت خطا فادح اخر فتحت قناه
مع هذه الحكومه حتى قبل تشكيلها كما يعني
اعترف يعني حسين الشيخ في المقابله التي
اجراها بالتلفزيون فلسطين قناه مع مع
الحكومه التي تقول انها تريد ان تصفي
القضيه الفلسطينيه ولا تكتفي بالاقوال
وانما تنفذ هذه الاقوال في كل المجالات
وعلى كل المستويات والاصعده نحن هذه
الحكومه سيد هاني المصري هذه الحكومه هنا
انتقل للسيد فيزيكراولي هذه الحكومه حتى
داخل اسرائيل الانتقادات ضدها قويه جدا
الى درجه ان الصحفي الاسرائيلي جدعون ليفي
قال بان ما ينتظر
الفلسطينيين في الفتره المقبله هي مجازر
على طريقه صبرا وشاتيلا هو يقول نحن لم
نتحرك يقصد الاسرائيليين لم نتحرك عندما
قامت الكتائب بمجزره صبره وشاتيلا في 82
الان لا نتحرك وسنشهد صبرا وشاتيلا اذا لم
تقع محاكمه هؤلاء هل تعتقد بان واشنطن في
وارد ان تدعم
محاسبه هؤلاء ان كانت تريد فعلا ان تعطي
نفس جديد لتفهمات فلسطينيه اسرائيليه
انا في تقدير اعتقد ان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه قلقه بخصوص تشكيله هذه الحكومه
وقالت ذلك في الخفاء
والعديد من المسؤولين الامريكيين قالوا
بانهم لم يتواصلوا مع اي من الوزراء
المتطرفين الذين يخرجون به تصريحات متطرفه
تحدثنا
ويجب ان اقول بان هذه هي الحكومه
المنتخبه في البلد الامريكيه تعمل على
اداره هذه العلاقه الصعبه الان علينا ان
ننظر كيف ستكون فتره حكومه او فتره حكم
هذه الحكومه الراهنه الان وكيف ستصمد والى
متى نعم هناك قلق من جانبنا كلنا
هذا طبعا بالمقارنه مع حكومات كانت في
تسعينيات وفي بدايه الفيه الان نرى بان
المشهد السياسي
الاسرائيلي ينحى ناحيه اليمين اكثر في
اكثر
وليس هناك اتجاه سياسيه في مرحله غنائيه
يسعى لي حل النزاع الفلسطيني الاسرائيلي
وطبعا هذا يعتبر مشكل كبير بالنسبه
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ليس هناك الان امكانيه للقيام بتنازلات من
الطرفين من طرف الفلسطيني والاسرائيلي
والان اعتقد بدانا نبتعد اكثر فاكثر عن
العمليه السياسيه ولكن بناء على ما تفضلت
به الان تحديدا في ظل هذا المشهد الذي
وصفته انت كما يجب كيف يمكن للولايات
المتحده ان تقدم يد العون لهذه الحكومه
كيف عندما تجتمع اطراف الاردن مصر القياده
الفلسطينيه اسرائيل مع الولايات المتحده
في العقبه ويكون الحديث عن انشاء قوه
فلسطينيه
بخمسه الاف عنصر امن لضبط الامن بين قوسين
في نابلس وفي جنين وهذا مشروع فتنه
فلسطينيه مثل ما اشار ضيفنا من رام الله
يعني عوض التوجه لكبح جماح السياسه
الاسرائيليه يتم الضغط على الجانب
الفلسطيني لكبح جماح مقاومه ضد الاحتلال
دعونا ننظر للامر بهذه الطريقه ان شئنا
ابينا فاسرائيل والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه حليفين استراتيجيين وهما
يتعاونان على قضايا مختلفه ايران احدهما
طبعا واهمهما
وهذه احد التحديات ايضا بالنسبه للجانب
الفلسطيني بالنظر الى اين نقف الان موقعنا
بما كنا فيه قبل عشره خمسه عشر سنه الان
طبعا بالنسبه
القضيه الاكثر اهميه هي ايران في مدرسه
البيه مساعيها وطموحاتها النوويه وايضا
دعمها لروسيا في حرب هذه اوكرانيا الرئيس
الان يركز ايضا على قضيه اخرى كالصين
الهجره ايران وايضا التضخم القضيه
الفلسطينيه الاسرائيليه طبعا مصدر قلق لكن
ليست على قمه هرم الاهتمامات الامريكيه
والاولويات الامريكيه في الوقت الراهن اذن
الطموح الذي يسعى اليه اتفاق العقبه طبعا
هو تلا في تزايد التوتر لكن دعونا نرى اين
يمكن الوصول في افق سته اشهر الان ليس
هناك
سعيه حقيقي من قبل واشنطن لحل هذه
المشاكل بنفس القدر الذي كان سائدا قبل
عشره خمسه عشره دكتور في الاحد تحدثنا على
الجانب الاسرائيلي تحدثنا عن الجانب
الفلسطيني الجانب الامريكي ماذا عن مصر
والاردن وقد شارك في هذا الاجتماع وبدا
وكانهما متحمستين للدفع في مقاربه من هذا
النوع
كيف نفسر هذا الموقف يعني الموقف الاردني
والموقف المصري هو يعني محكوم باكثر من
عامل اولا ان
ارتفاع نسبه التوتر هو ليس لمصلحه البلدين
وبالنهايه المشاركه المصريه الاردنيه هي
تاتي من اجل خدمه المواقف الاردنيه
المصريه وليس من اجل خدمه القضيه
الفلسطينيه بهذا الاتجاه هذا واحد ثانيا
ان الموقف الاردني والمصري هو يرتبط
بالاساس بالموقف الامريكي يعني هناك
الصوره الاكبر التي تديرها الولايات
المتحده وهي مساله خفض التوتر وهو
بالمناسبه محمد هو اولويه امريكيه خفض
التواتر هو ليس اولويه فلسطينيه ولا
اولويه اسرائيليه ايضا ولا تسال الحكومه
الاسرائيليه في ارتفاع نسبه التوتر او
انخفاضه وهو مساله اولويه امريكيه
والمواقف المصريه والاردنيه هي ايضا تفهم
اللعبه الدوليه وتتفاهم ان وتعلم ان هذه
اولويه امريكيه وتحاول ان تنسجم معها
بنهايه هذا يعني بنهايه المطاف الولايات
المتحده المشكله جذر المشكله انا برايي هو
ليس ليس مرتبط في الحكومه الاسرائيليه هو
مرتبط ايضا بموقف الاداره الامريكيه حاليا
موقف اداره جو بايدن التي تاتي يعني من
بهذا الاساس من اجل خفض نسبه التوتر في
المناطق حتى لا تضطر ان تتخذ موقف يتناقض
مع الازمه الاخلاقيه التي تسببها التوتر
في الاراضي الفلسطينيه مع المعركه كما
ذكرلي وهو مصيب بذلك ان الاولويه هي
لاوكرانيا الولايات المتحده هي تشن حرب
اخلاقيه في اوكرانيا ولا اخلاقيه في
فلسطين وهذا هذا هذا التناقض اللي هو في
المواقف الامريكيه سيكلف الولايات المتحده
ثمن كبير في اداره معركتها في اوكرانيا في
في مواجهه المد الروسي هناك
هذا السبب الاداره الامريكيه سياسته التي
لا تتغير ضمن طالما ان الحرب في اوكرانيا
مستمره هي الاحتواء وليس اداره ولا حتى
اداره يعني بالزمان كنا نتحدث عن اداره
الصراع هي حتى ليس هذا هو احتواء للصراع
واحتواء للتوتر حتى لا تضطر الولايات
المتحده ان تظهر بموقف المتناقض في
السياسه الدوليه في ما بين اوكرانيا وفي
فلسطين وكان ان على الفلسطيني ان يدفع
الثمن لوحده
الفلسطيني بهذا بما يحدث في الوقت الحالي
هو الذي يدفع الثمن والقياده الفلسطينيه
هي
انسجمت مع التوجهات الامريكيه ليس لحل
صراع ولا لادارته ولكن لخفض التوتر من اجل
ان لا تدفع اداره جو بايدن الثمن اداره جو
بايدن هي من وضعت نفسها بهذه النطاق بهذا
التناقض المريب على الساحه وهي من تتحمل
مسؤوليته لماذا على مواطن في حواره ان وفي
نابلس ان يتحمل مسؤوليات اداره جو بايدن
بهذا التناقض الاخلاقي الذي خلقته لنفسها
على الساحه الدوليه والمطلوب من القياده
الفلسطينيه ان تخفض التوتر من اجل هذا
فباعتقادي هذه هي المشكله بالاداره
الامريكيه الحاليه المشكله في جو بايدن
نفسه حتى هناك كثير من داخل الاداره
الامريكي ونحن نتابع التصريحات التي تصدر
من الخارجيه الامريكيه
يعرف هذا الكلام موقف الخارجيه المشكله
حتى هي في في جو بايدن نفسه هذا الذي عرف
نفسه بانه صهيوني في اخر زياره له وهو وما
زال يمارس صهيونيه على اعلى المستويات هذه
هي المشكله وليس من المطلوب من الفلسطيني
ان يدفع الثمن لوحده وبالتالي هذا هو
الموقف الامريكي وتنسجم معه الاداره
الحكومه الاسرائيليه والقياده الفلسطينيه
وكذلك مصر والاردن فنحن يعني ليس متوقع ان
نطالب من المصريين والاردنيين ان يكونوا
فلسطينيه فلسطينيين اكثر من الفلسطينيين
انفسهم الذين يوافقون على حضور مثل هذه
الاجتماعات ويعطون شرعيه لحكومه بن غفير
في الاثناء التركيز ربما حاليا السيد هاني
المصري كما اتضح من كلام السيد رياض منصور
مندوب فلسطين في الامم المتحده هو استغلال
الوضع الحالي وهذا التصعيد الاسرائيلي في
القمع في نابلس وفي جنين وفي اريحا لاعاده
تحريك موضوع الحمايه الدوليه للفلسطينيين
هذا المطلب هل يمكن ان يلقى اي تجاوب لان
المطلب قديم ولكن ربما الان السياق قد
يسمح بان يتم التعامل معه باكثر جديه
اولا
جزء من التفاهمات التي حدثت في العقبه وما
قبل العقبه هو ان توقف السلطه الفلسطينيه
جهودها في الامم المتحده وفي المحاكم
الدوليه وهذا طبعا خطا فظيع ولكن ايضا
المبالغه بالرهان على دور الامم المتحده
وعلى دور المحاكم الدوليه وكان المساله هي
مساله حقوقيه وان العدل سياخذ مجرى يعني
في هذه المناطق هذا يعني ايضا وهم ورهان
خاسر يعني صدر من الامم المتحده ومن مجلس
الامن ومن محكمه العدل الدوليه يعني مئات
القرارات ولم ينفذ منها يعني ولا قرار
واحد لان هناك حمايه يعني امريكيه
لاسرائيل وتعامل معها كدوله فوق القانون
الدولي وبالتالي استمرار الحديث عن
الحمايه الدوليه وكانها في متناول اليد
هذا يعني تضيع وقت
ويمنعنا من السير بالاتجاه الذي مفروض ان
نسير فيه ما يجب ان نسير فيه هو التركيز
على الصمود الفلسطيني على استمرار الوجود
الفلسطيني على ارض فلسطين لان المخططات
التي في جعبه الحكومه الاسرائيليه الحاليه
هي مخططات
للتهجير وللقتل
ولجميعنا في معازل
شان عدوان على قطاع غزه وربما ايضا حروب
اقليميه خاصه في ظل الازمه التي تعيشها
اسرائيل والذي هي ازمه كبيره ليست تتعلق
بالموضوع الفلسطيني للاسف هناك اجماع بين
الحكومه والمعارضه على الموضوع الفلسطيني
ولكن تتعلق بقضايا لتتعلق في طبيعه
اسرائيل هويه اسرائيل ديموقراطيه اسرائيل
موضوع دور الدين في النظام في دوله
اسرائيل لكل هذه المسائل التي اذا نج
الحكومه الاسرائيليه في مخططاتها القضائيه
وغيرها ستحول اسرائيل الى دوله ديكتاتوريه
في الكامل وهذا سيعني انها ستنتقل الى
معداء وعمل اكبر لتصفيه القضيه الفلسطينيه
وهي تراهن على بقائها لمده سنتين الى حين
اجراء الانتخابات الامريكيه القادمه وهذا
ليس انا اقوله من عندي وانما هم يقولونه
واتفقوا عليه مع نتنياهو اثناء المباحثات
حول تشكيل الحكومه كان دائما نتنياهو يقول
لهم اصبروا سنتين اسبوع عشان هيك حلل
الاداره المدنيه حسب الاتفاق بعد سنتين
لانهم يراهنوا عن نجاح ترامب او من هو
شبيه فيه وفي هذه الحاله سيكون هناك دعم
امريكي كبير لهذه الحكومه وهذا يدفع
المنطقه الى انفجارات لا حدود لها والى
مواجهات كبيره جدا
نسال سيد كراولي باختصار شديد ثم انهي مع
دكتور فريحات هنا في ظلمه بحثناها لحد
الان توقعاتك للفتره المقبله بين التهدئه
والتصعيد ومزيد التصعيد ربما
في تقدير شخصيه ان المشكل الاساسي
للفلسطينيين ولا الاسرائيليين في المرحله
الراهنه لديهم ما يكفي من الدعم من اجل ان
نقول بان الوضع يمكن ان يؤول الى التهدئه
الحكومه الاسرائيليه والسلطه الفلسطينيه
كلاهما في كافه التجاذبات ما بين الجهات
التي تدعو لتعصب وتطرف فبالتالي هناك حاجه
لوضع اطرف على سكه الحوار وهذا ربما احد
الاسباب الذي يدفع المتحده الامريكيه
لتقوم بما بامكانها من اجل تقويه
الفلسطينيين من اجل السيطره على المناطق
الخاضع الهواء ايضا امريكا تشجع
الاسرائيليين من اجل التنميه والتطرفين
على الانخراط فيه المزيد من التطور هذا قد
ينجح كما قد يفشل نحن في وضع متقلب للغايه
ولا اي طرف من اطراف ليس بواسع السيطره
على وضع في محاره هنا دكتور فريحات
يعني توقعاتك للمرحله المقبله انا
باعتقادي المرحله المكرره لن يحدث هناك اي
تغيير جوهري هذه التفاهمات لن تصمد امام
الواقع جذور المشكله هي موجوده والتفاهمات
لا تعالج جذور المشكله الجذور هي تتمثل
بالاحتلال تتمثل
بالنشاط الاستيطاني الذي لا يتوقف عن قدم
وابتلاء الارض الفلسطينيه في الضفه
الغربيه هذه الجذور هي موجوده والتفاهمات
هي يعني في واد اخر ليس لها علاقه بجذور
المشكله فطالما ان مثل هذه الجزر هي
موجوده هي ستبقى سبب في ارتفاع حده التوتر
وليس
وليس وليس وقف ولا ولا حله والاداره
الامريكيه وهي الطرف الوحيد التي لديها
نفوذ وبامكانها ان تمارس مثل هذا النموذ
على مثل هذه الحكومه الفاشيه في تل ابيب
لا تريد ان تستخدم مثل هذا النفود ولن
تستخدم مثل هذا النفوذ لانها في واد اخر
هناك لها اولوياتها هناك لها اوكرانيا
والصين وروسيا وكل ما تريده وان لا تريد
توتر وعنف في الفراد المناطق الفلسطينيه
يشتتها عن مثل هذا الموضوع القياده
الفلسطينيه باعتقاد انه حان الاوان او انا
الاوان ان تفهم بانها وهي تتعامل ربما
بحسن النيات بمثل باجتماع العقبه او الى
اخره انها بنهايه المطاف تتحول الى حصان
طرواده
الطرف الفلسطيني كان في العقبه حصان
طرواده الذي اعطى شرعيه لهذه الحكومه
اليمينيه العنصريه من اجل ان يتم تسويق
عالميا وخرج ورجع بدون ان يكون بخفي حنين
دون ان يكون هناك وقف للنشاط الاستيطاني
شكرا لك دكتور ابراهيم فريحات على حضورك
شكرا لضيفنا من رام الله هاني المصري
لضيفنا ايضا من واش
شكرا لكم جميعا كالعاده ننهي بتغريدات
لمسؤولين وكتاب حول موضوع هذه الحلقه
البدايه من رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
بنيامين نتنياهو الذي يقول خلافا
للتغريدات البناء وتسويه البؤر في يهودا
والسامره بالطبع يقصد الضفه الغربيه
يتواصلان وفقا لجدول التخطيط والبناء
الاصلي دون اي تغيير لا يوجد ولن يكون
هناك اي تجميد للبناء وزير الماليه
الاسرائيلي ورئيس حزب الصهيونيه الدينيه
كتب على تويتر يقول ليس لدي اي فكره عما
تحدثوا عنه او لم يتحدثوا عنه في الاردن
سمعت عن هذا المؤتمر غير الضروري من وسائل
الاعلام مثلكم تماما لكنني اعرف شيئا
واحدا لن يكون هناك تجميد للبناء والتطوير
في المستوطنات ولا حتى ليوم واحد سيواصل
الجيش الاسرائيلي العمل لمكافحه الارهاب
في جميع مناطق يهودا والسامره دون اي قيود
زعيم المعارضه الاسرائيليه يئير لبيت قال
في تغريده ميليشيا
شرعت في حرق حواره لنصف اجتماع العقبه
وهذه الحكومه تشكل خطرا على اسرائيل
الدكتور صالح النعامي الخبير في الشؤون
الاسرائيليه غرد يقول تخيلوا ان نجم قمه
العقبه هو المجرم رونين بارك رئيس جهاز
الشباك الصهيوني المسؤول المباشر عن تنفيذ
جميع المجازر التي يرتكبها الاحتلال في
الضفه وغزه في وقت تعتصر قلوب ذوي الشهداء
شهداء مجزره نابلس يوشك هذا الارهابي على
تناول الطعام طعام الغداء في مدينه عربيه
ونختم بهذه التغريده للكاتب السعودي
والمدير العام السابق للاساس والدكتور عبد
العزيز التويجري يقول لم يكد اجتماع
العقبه ينعقد بحضور ممثلين عن الشرطه
الفلسطينيه والاردن والكيان الصهيوني
برعايه امريكيه حتى قام المستوطنون
الصهاينه بالهجوم على القرى الفلسطينيه
وحرق سيارات الفلسطينيين والباتش بهم اي
سلام يتحدثون عنه
في امان الله
[موسيقى]